okay so when marvel announced the 10
lives of wolverine i was like oh my god
right because like benjamin percy's
writing it dude here's the thing
benjamin percy is one of those writers
where he never disappoints and this this
dude this story is so ridiculously good
i am so excited to see
where this goes oh my god okay so as far
as i understand it marvel's basically
switching back and forth so you've got
10 lives of wolverine and the 10 deaths
of wolverine now the 10 lives of
wolverine is a five issue series and the
ten deaths of wolverine is a five issue
series so i believe they're alternating
every two weeks so what we'll end up
doing is actually jumping back and forth
we'll kind of cover them as they go
along and sort of call it a day uh but
as always we'll keep it confined to a
playlist so it's easy for you guys to
keep track of so you don't have to like
keep track of it yourselves right i mean
my job is to make it easier for you guys
to navigate my videos the easier it is
to navigate my videos the more likely
you are to watch them and that's always
good for business so
[Laughter]
here's the thing this initially picks up
with wolverine having this bit of a
conversation about time right and the
funny thing about this is wolverine has
been around for like 200 years he's been
around for a ridiculously long time
probably longer than that to be honest
and so he's seen things go from like
basic timepieces to like advanced
technology or at least technology as it
exists right now and one of the things
he comments about is that he doesn't
like the idea of a digital clock because
it gives this perception that time can
stand still because as he says it sells
the lie of a singular moment that does
not exist right that's already gone and
he says a proper watch lets you see the
possibility of all time that's the truth
i know from more than a century of
living it's not overly important here
it's just one of these things where when
you look at an actual clock you
basically see the face of that clock
right like all those minutes all those
hours right ticking down to a particular
thing but ultimately he's told by
charles xavier it's time and so what we
end up doing here is jumping back to the
past with what's basically the mother of
charles xavier in the process of giving
birth now this is not really benjamin
percy changing anything at least not yet
right the history of charles xavier is
still seemingly intact right that his
father and his mother were alive or at
least of course she was alive when he
was born but his father is alive when
he's born it wasn't until later on in
life in his really adolescent years that
his father actually died and then his
mother remarried but at the moment right
now it's just kind of charles xavier
basically being born now the crazy thing
about this is that the father of xavier
basically calls out to bowers who is
essentially the groundskeeper right the
gardener the guy who's there to
basically you know tend to the garden
and make sure that it looks pretty and
the guy throws a set of shears at him
out of nowhere now of course wolverine
shows up here and saves this guy and
we'll talk about how wolverine shows up
here in the past here in a little bit
because this is present day wolverine in
the past just not wolverine from the
past well it kind of is but it kind of
is we'll talk about that here in a
second but basically bowers is seemingly
possessed and what he has on his head is
basically the symbol of omega red which
is really weird because arcadey didn't
show up until much later on right he's
not until you get into like the cold war
era and even a little bit before the
cold war that he actually became a
prominent figure and then was eventually
transformed into omega red so at the
moment right now omega red's about 150
years early to to fight wolverine
he's not supposed to be there yet but
it's kind of crazy because they look
similar right now of course he's also
basically got his tentacle appendages
and basically goes through and starts
attacking wolverine of course the idea
is for him to basically track down and
to basically destroy uh charles xavier
seemingly before he's born now as far as
that goes what we actually know doing is
jumping back to the present day at the
hatchery of course those of you guys who
recall the hatchery from the entirety of
jonathan hickman's x-men run that's
where dead mutants are basically reborn
and what ends up happening here is that
omega red overpowers one of the five and
then basically uses him to access a kind
of hidden archive right where basically
only the five and like charles xavier
magneto members of the kauai council are
able to access what he's looking for is
documentation that they actually have
the ability to create the carbonadium
synthesizer now one of the things to
know that that's going on with omega red
at the moment in the x-men comics and
honestly we haven't covered the
wolverine solo series for a little while
so that might be something that we
should go back and do or at least kind
of pick up with once this is over i
don't want to cover two different
wolverine stories at the same time it
might end up throwing people off uh
basically omega red was tricked into
working for dracula under the idea that
dracula could give him the carbonation
synthesizer and that once that didn't
work out the x-men on kakoa were like
well we can give you the carbonation
synthesizer all you have to do is work
for us the reason why this matters is
because carbonation is a poisonous
substance and that's what's bonded to
omega red right in a lot of ways he's a
poor man's version of wolverine right
things like the red room and stuff like
that that was all basically russia's
attempt to duplicate weapons plus
weapons two through ten really right the
programs that basically created like
frank simpson and gave us wolverine and
then eventually deadpool things like
that russia had always tried to
duplicate that but never with the same
level of success but the way that a lot
of people usually end up using omega red
is by enticing him with the idea of the
carbonation synthesizer because that's
what would stabilize him it would keep
the metal in his body from quite
literally killing him and he's always on
the hunt for a carbanium synthesizer now
when i say they don't have the carbanium
synthesizer that's probably a little bit
of a misnomer here so the idea was the
resurrection protocol for omega red to
basically find a way to bring him back
that the deal that was brokered is that
they would give them a carbonation
synthesizer what was actually going on
behind the scenes was a lot more just
dubious right that a carbonation
synthesizer was being developed by forge
and it was going to be given to omega
red but what the new version was going
to contain was additional remote
operating devices and surveillance
trackers in effect they would give omega
red as a carbonation synthesizer but
they would attach strings to it that he
would basically be a puppet for the the
quiet council for the mutant nation of
kakawa he would lose his agency right he
would lose his ability to operate of his
own accord now a lot of this and what
was really interesting is that a kind of
complaint was issued like why are we
doing this right like if we are agreeing
to basically resurrect omega red and the
event that he dies then why not just
take away the carbonadium that's
poisoning him right why not just
resurrect him in a purified form as
opposed to creating some carbonadium
synthesizer that's going to allow us to
treat him like some kind of animal that
we keep on a leash the response of beast
which is pretty pretty extreme here is
you are a creator of technology for
kakoa and you will create the technology
that you are assigned to create so
create what we told you to make the
quiet council the the those in power in
krakowa are seemingly just as crooked as
the various human populations that they
condemn for their own corruption and so
on and so forth and so jumping back to
the past this is where things get really
really cool because what you end up
getting is basically the birth of
cassandra nova now what's kind of
interesting here is benjamin percy rolls
with the punches when it comes to
cassandra nova as a character so for
those of us who don't know about her
cassandra nova was created a new x-men
right she was well she was cool i mean
she was introduced in e is for
extinction but you didn't really get a
definitive origin for her until much
much later it was really a combination
of the new x-men stories and messiah
complex but the whole idea behind
cassandra nova is she's what you call a
mummerdy basically she is the antithesis
to charles xavier normally they only
exist in a spiritual form and basically
try to destroy their opposite in the
case of cassandra nova she gave herself
a physical body and that's what was born
here now in the old comics in the old
origins she was still born or at least
believed to have been stillborn and then
ultimately survived benjamin percy
includes that here and i'm a little
shocked because the whole story of
cassandra nova was i wouldn't say
controversial because this is comics uh
but it was one of those things that a
lot of fans disagreed with when when it
all happened right like it just seemed
kind of silly a little pointless a
little nonsensical but people just sort
of went with it right i mean the actions
of cassandra nova were awesome right
massacring 16 million mutants on the
island of genocide that was great
i mean it wasn't great that she did it
you know but like the es4 extinction
story arc is awesome
if ever there is an x-men story that you
should read it is e is for extinction
god that story was great we covered it
we'll have a link to it down in the
description i'll have my editor jacob
put a link in there but of course this
kind of follows the the standard of
cassandra no but now this is all we
really see right we don't really get a
whole lot of her in fact we don't need
to the fight between wolverine and
basically bowers right who's seemingly
possessed by some version of omega red
or something along those lines that
fights pretty straightforward and it's
one of those funny things because
wolverine's kind of like you're never
getting into this house and you're never
killing basically charles xavier that's
not going to happen and the funny thing
is bowers returns to his normal self and
then suddenly wolverine looks to the
window and realizes that basically the
the butler of the xavier family now has
his gun turned on the father of charles
xavier so whatever's going on here
seemingly the spirit of omega red or
what have you is able to jump from one
person to the next now we don't fully
know if it is omega red at least not yet
but of course this basically leads to
the father of xavier just blowing apart
the the uh the butler right i mean he
literally blows this guy to pieces with
what looks like an elephant gun right
just a double barrel shotgun let me tell
you something man if you're ever looking
to do somebody in that'll do the job
right it'll get the job done man it's
it's like as a as a guy who is a fan of
guns i promise you there are there are
some out there that are way more than
you need and and that is more than you
need right it's more than enough to take
the head off of somebody
and so because i don't know why i'm
laughing about that like i don't know
why i think that's funny but what ends
up happening of course is basically this
kind of spiritual essence jumps from the
butler directly into i wouldn't call her
a maid i'd call her more like a birth
mother i don't know that's really an
antiquated term honestly i don't really
care uh but basically ends up jumping to
her right and then in turn in the
reflection the father of charles xavier
sees omega red so that's exactly what it
looks like the spiritual essence of
omega red has basically found a way to
travel into the past and is now trying
to kill charles xavier why we don't
fully know of course wolverine basically
comes to the rescue and that's when you
start to get a full idea of what's
basically going on here right jumping
back to the modern day you end up having
charles xavier lead uh wolf reign into
what's basically a hidden place right
where they keep the helmet of cerebra
and that with jean grey along for the
ride it's very much days of future past
and it's kind of interesting because
benjamin percy is borrowing from the
actions of the film and the plot of the
comic in the sense that in the comic it
was rachel summers right that alternate
reality uh daughter of jean grey and and
cyclops who's who sent the mind of kitty
pride into the past whereas in the movie
it was the mind of wolverine that was
sent into the past that basically
wolverine's mind is teleported into
history in order to ensure the survival
of charles xavier because seemingly
omega red whether he's been contracted
to do it or because he's chosen to do it
on his own most likely he's been
contracted because omega red's kind of
an idiot has basically found a way to
travel into the past and then try to
kill charles xavier and that's why
wolverine's here is to basically save
the life of xavier during all these
different assassination attempts and so
during this whole thing with this great
big huge fight that's going on one thing
that's not explained here is how it is
that the tendrils of omega red are able
to manifest in people who are just there
right just random people it looks like
it's just kind of like bone right it
looks like it's literally just bone
protrusions so seemingly it's the
ability to just kind of manipulate the
bone structure of the individuals he
possesses in order to create tendrils
and then use those to ensnare people
it's pretty eloquent in terms of how
it's done because at this point in time
in terms of the history of the marvel
universe wolverine has not undergone the
adamantium treatment yet so he still has
bone claws so if if omega red would have
just kind of show up here right just
sort of teleport himself to the past
that seemingly he would have carbonation
he'd tear wolverine to pieces wolverine
would never have a chance right i mean
just rip his head off of his body and
according to the xavier protocols that's
all you got to do right that'd be the
end of him now of course with everything
going on the mother of of of xavier just
basically pulls out this elephant gun
and it's like i don't know what's going
on here but both of you get out of here
now right like leave this place and do
not ever come back and so switching back
to the to the present day following
omega red's realization of what krakow
intended to do with the carbonation
synthesizer that they were going to give
him he passes through one of the cochon
gates and then travels to russia and the
crazy thing is of course he overpowers a
couple guards here and there nothing too
big going on and then once he enters
into the kremlin seemingly he's met by
mikhail rasputin now here's the thing it
looks like mikhail rasputin it might not
be right but it looks like mikhail
rasputin and let me tell you guys
something man if mikhail rasputin is
involved in this
right and it's one of those crazy things
because what it looks like is michael
rasputin and many people under him have
basically seized control of russia right
that the president of russia has
essentially been compromised and there's
even some notes that are left there from
sage's logbook that like it looks like
it's mchale and mikhail rasputin's uh
doing right that he's trying to create
possibly some some kind of geopolitical
crisis but regardless of what his own
personal motivations are i
love mikhail rasputin this guy's so cool
one of the best things he can do is use
people's powers against them by
manipulating energy so like when he was
fighting iceman for example and he
turned his body solid it's just stuff
like that right just things like that
mchill rasputin is just he's he's great
he's not overpowered right he's just
powerful enough that he's a legitimate
credible threat but he's not so
overpowered that he seems ridiculous
right he's just he's just a great
villain just a great villain i love
mikhail rasputin right this guy's just
phenomenal but of course wolverine
basically ends up stepping in of course
once the you know once xavier falls in
the arms of sharon ends up cutting the
umbilical cord and then tells like that
like you know the omega red possessed
maid or or birth weather or whatever
like come and get him right of course
because omega red's an idiot he goes
charging and then in turn wolverine
moves out of the way and that leads to
this woman just flying out of the window
and then basically crashing onto the
ground below and so what it does from
here is we don't really get any kind of
conclusion right this seemingly this
failed assassination attempt against
xavier is resolved from there you jump
to the 1960s right when wolverine was
part of team x when he was basically out
there serving alongside like like
sabertooth and maverick and mastodon and
those guys although really it only looks
like the three of them and then when all
this is going on wolverine's like i have
no idea what's like what in the world is
happening of course saber two seemingly
saves them and it's just like wolverine
basically ends up taking over the body
of himself so seemingly he was just kind
of out there right just just he was
there but didn't really seem to know
exactly what's going on and even now he
seems somewhat lost and jean grey
basically appears as she says like you
are in colombia wolverine and the target
you're looking for is 25 miles south by
southwest of here right you have to save
xavier the clock is ticking what's
basically going on here through the 10
lives of wolverine is that wolverine's
mind is being sent to different points
in its own history in order to save the
life of charles xavier and seemingly
what's happening here is benjamin percy
is tying those things into existing
events or creating new events because
for those of you guys who are familiar
with the history of wolverine and team x
you guys know a lot of important things
go down in colombia some of the more
significant moments of wolverine's own
past take place in colombia so i am very
very curious to see what direction this
goes in but i'm on board man i am
excited for this with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace